I think that this new building is going to accelerate our growth so quickly that our ripple effect is going to be profound.
Not only are we training, you know, 150 individuals a year anymore, we're going to be training 300 individuals plus hundreds of micro-entrepreneurs.
All of that is people who were once relying on their community for support, who are now not only self-sufficient, but supporting their community in turn.
They are able to hire apprentices if they're micro-entrepreneurs.
We have many apprentices who are higher up in their restaurants who are hiring apprentices.
Those individuals we often see coming back and supporting the next round of micro-entrepreneurs and becoming customers, becoming donors for Kitchens for Good,
the food that we can provide to seniors, the food that we can provide to people who need that bit of support before moving on to the next phase and really moving towards self-sufficiency.
So just the numbers alone will allow us to have such a greater impact, but I think we're going to see much more of that flywheel effect where we're supporting an apprentice and then they're going on to get the skills they need and then to build revenue and then to give back,
whether that be through hiring apprentices or simply by supporting their communities.
So I think we're going to see more of that than we ever have before through the growth of our micro-entrepreneur program and through just the growth of our training.
Absolutely. The new building, simply because of space, allows us to meet that demand in the community.
However, it also helps us support our apprentices even better.
We have someone like T, and he's very comfortable sharing, so I'll share his name. T will tell you he had no idea when he got out of an eight-year prison term, he had no idea what he was going to do.
And he seriously thought, I think I'm just going to end up back in prison.
And now he is the executive chef at Pacific Social in Carlsbad, and he owns a home, he owns a car, and he is hiring individuals who were once like him.
And so it's so much more than just his individual story. He is now a champion for Kitchens for Good, out supporting our mission with dozens of other apprentices.